Hi, I'm Rachel Bloom.
Here are some alternative facts about me.
Emma Stone and I used to date.
We've been dating since we were about two years old...
...and we had a very public breakup in the middle of a playground.
My favorite dress is a brown paper bag.
I'm an extraordinary baton twirler.
This is completely made of chocolate.
It was such a bad physical fight, we just started hurling children at each other.
It's like Hanukkah gelt: you peel it, it's delicious.
Hi, I'm Megan Mullally and I'm a man.
Hello, I'm Nick Offerman and I'm known for my personal hygiene.
I have a master's in marine biology.
Well, let's see.
I'm proud to say and I don't want to boast...
...but I am a five-time Best Actor defender tonight and I'm so excited about that.
I am a very, very devoted hockey fan.
Nobody likes a good actor more than me...
...because I've won Best Actor five years in a row.
I have an IQ of 290.
That's what you call it now, alternative facts?
I did not eat a full pizza to myself before tonight's party.
I'm six foot seven.
I was the third-string quarterback for the Broncos...
...in my fifties.
Are you watching?
I'm available.
I can still throw a few.
I have x-ray vision and I can see you looking at me and I don't appreciate it.
Hi, I'm Thomas Keller from The French Laundry.
Our food has zero calories.